you know here you are now you got your
own weed
company like your dream has come true
yeah there it is diablo oh yeah look
it's in these little tins aren't they
adorable beautiful
let me see it let me open it up it's
really taking time with this
i mean that that doesn't look like the
weed that i used to buy when i was a kid
it was all seeds that's beautiful
these are really it's uh yeah they're
nice big buds we sell big buds
we sell big buds i'm thinking you're
going to become a billionaire because
i think people trust you especially like
reading your book
is very very honest and you seem to be a
man of integrity
you know you take a stand on a lot of
things and i think people trust you with
this weed
how actively involved are you in this i
mean are you hugely i spend
as much time working on it as as i do
film and
and our other things and we've been
working on this for almost 10 years and
truthfully like i view it i love it i
love weed and
and i've seen that i'm able to talk
about it and communicate
what i love about it in a way that that
people
other people who love weed that
they uh they it was they received it
well you know
well he relates to it um you've always
been honest about your weed use and i
i trust that you would have a good
product i do i wanted this to reflect
me and my sensibilities and and what i
love and
and that's why like you know we spent so
much time on the packaging and the
design because
to us that was very important to me it
was super important that
that weed look good and that it be
treated like a good
product like weed to me is one of the
best products
there is you know and in a world where
like our headphones get
beautiful packaging and you know things
that are objectively not incredibly
special
get treated very special um i
very firmly felt that weed should be
treated that way and that we should
create a product that feels very
considered and very
thoughtful and by doing that i thought
it would destigmatize
weed in general because if something is
presented
in a thoughtful considered way it makes
it
seem less illicit it makes it seem um
less controversial you know um it makes
it
seem more uh more like any other great
product that that is being elevated by
the people who are who are selling it
you know and so
that was really a lot of the philosophy
behind what we wanted to do with
houseplant was like we kept saying like
we want to be
the company that we deserve what kind of
boss are you
would you allow your employees to smoke
weed
at the job are they allowed to they are
oh yeah as long as it doesn't impede
their
performance or their ability to do their
job like i'd be the most hypocritical
boss in the universe if i told people
they couldn't smoke weed